>> Okay.
Hello, I'm Erik Charas.
I'm from Mozambique.
I'm a young global leader.
And I'm here to state the importance on access
to information
especially inclusive -- inclusivity for the
poor.
When you look at getting out of poverty, one
of the fundamental pillars
that exists, or that should be there, is that
people should be
informed, people should know what goes on
in the lives in the world,
they should be included in society rather
than excluded.
And if we don't make provision that news,
general information gets to
the poor, there's very little difficulty -- very
little of -- well,
there's a lot of difficulty for them to actually
become included in the
general economic of society.
Well, when you look at one of the Davos questions
which is about
education and poverty, you'll find out that
most of the developing
countries, one of the things that is happening
is that very few
children actually do attend to go to school.
And those that do do not get the ability to
practice the reading, to
actually get informed of what goes on in the
world, to become aware of
the circumstances that surround them, and
therefore be better equipped
with tools that would allow them to fight
for their own future.
So when you address the issue of poverty and
education, it is extremely
important to consider the access to information.
And the majority of the population in the
poorer communities in the
world, do not have access to things like television,
newspapers,
Internet.
For example in a place like Mozambique, less
than ten percent of the
population has access to electricity.
That limits their capacity to be connected
when you look at economical
ability, most of them can't afford to buy
a television, can't afford to
buy a computer or be connected to the Internet.
When you look at for example the readership,
there's six million people
that can read, but newspapers exist in the
form of economy, less than
10,000.
So you are targeting less than .1 percent
of the population that can
actually afford to read and write.
So it is supremely important that we push
on for this access to
information, making it widely available.
And some information that should just be public
to allow us to become
citizens in the global economy.
Okay.
That's my Davos date contribution.
Thank you very much.